martin scorsese's 2010 feature shutter
island is a gripping psychological
thriller with one twist after another
it's also the second highest grossing
movie of the director's career at first
the film appears to tell the story of
teddy daniels he's a us marshal
investigating the disappearance of a
patient named rachel salondo from a
mental hospital located on shutter
island an isolated outpost in boston
harbor for this case teddy is working
with his new partner chuck all while at
the hospital teddy begins experiencing
hallucinations nightmares and migraines
everything is strangely off in a way he
doesn't understand he goes deeper and
deeper down a rabbit hole of madness
until he finally confronts dr colley who
runs the shutter island facility cauley
explains to him that he's not really
teddy daniels instead he's andrew leytus
a traumatized man who killed his wife
after she drowned their three children
the disappearance teddy believes he's
been investigating has actually been an
experimental treatment to cure him of
his manic delusions the shutter island
doctors hope that by indulging latest
belief he is teddy daniels he'll be able
to come to the conclusion on his own
about what really happened and accept
what he did throughout this treatment
the hospital staff has been
participating in the elaborate charade
and chuck teddy's supposed partner isn't
even a us marshal don't you recognize me
andrew
i've been your primary psychiatrist for
the last two
years one of the great things about
shutter island is that it's a very
different experience watching the movie
with knowledge of the twist versus not
knowing the second time watching it you
can see all the ways scorsese hints at
what's really happening before it's
revealed in fact there are subtle clues
in the first few minutes of the film
while taking the ferry to shutter island
teddy is throwing up in the bathroom
which he thinks is because he's seasick
actually it's because he's withdrawing
from his medication and the ocean
reminds him of the water in which his
wife drowns her children then he goes up
to the deck and meets chuck his new
partner teddy doesn't seem to think it's
weird that he's meeting him for the
first time on deck logically they would
have gotten on the ferry together since
the film doesn't make a point of
underlining how strange teddy and
chuck's introduction is it's easy to
accept it as normal event but it's the
first bit of foreshadowing that things
are not what they seem at shutter island
and something is very off with teddy
there are other intriguing hints about
the shutter island twist contained in
the opening scene one such moment is
when teddy doesn't have a cigarette
lighter as a patient he's probably not
allowed to have one because it's a
dangerous item additionally the boat's
bathroom area looks suspiciously like
the kind of cell where a patient living
in a 1950s institution would be held but
it's the meeting of chuck and teddy that
should immediately tip off viewers that
something strange is afoot looking back
on the film numerous other clues lead up
to the big twist it's a movie that
rewards multiple viewings and you'll
realize certain moments come across
differently with the knowledge of
teddy's true identity for instance when
teddy and chuck first arrive on the
island the guards seem to tense up and
grip their rifles a little tighter
initially audiences may think that there
are secrets on the island they need to
protect in actuality the guards are
nervous because they know teddy's one of
the patients and they don't know if he
could snap at any second however the
biggest clue you might have missed
occurs when the us marshals are asked to
relinquish their guns there's a
prolonged moment where chuck fumbles
getting his firearm out of its holster
if he were actually an experienced
marshal he should have no problem
getting it undone the reason he has an
issue is that he's really a doctor and
he doesn't know how to handle a gun
properly at first the scene comes across
as amusing but it gives up the entire
twist right there with all this in mind
it just goes to show what a master
filmmaker martin scorsese is he hid all
of these clues in plain sight yet most
viewers were still taken by surprise
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you